who you gonna call hopefully Chris
Hemsworth because he's working reception
on the new reboot of Ghostbusters and
we've got photos of him looking all
secretarial I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update Ghostbusters is the
years highest-profile remake with the
1984 comedy classic being given a new
spin by bridesmaids and spy director
Paul Feig new promotional images have
now been released showing the all-female
ghost busting team and revealing Thor
star Chris Hemsworth secretary character
for the first time Ghostbuster stars
Kristen Wiig Melissa McCarthy Kate
McKinnon and Leslie Jones a number of
actors from the original movie will also
feature in cameos including Bill Murray
dan Aykroyd Ernie Hudson and sigourney
weaver in an interview with Empire last
year fig spoke about his decision to
reboot the film I have too much respect
for the original one to do a sequel he
said by a comic book movie there's also
the feeling of that once the world knows
ghosts and has seen them busted on such
a large scale they run the risk of
becoming pedestrian Ghostbusters will
arrive in cinemas on July 15 2016 who's
your favorite actress in the new
Ghostbusters let me know in the comments
or come and find me on Twitter I'm at
how not to draw thanks for watching and
for all your gaming and entertainment
news keep it gamespot